[Music]
so welcome everybody
to our session here at the berlin
science week on behalf of the eth zurich
that's the swiss federal institute of
technology
we are here to present to you
how science can can work in the service
of humanitarian aid and the title of our
session is rethinking humanitarian aid
we will have three case studies that we
will show to you of work that we're
doing
and it will
be followed by a panel discussion with
our panelists who i will
introduce shortly can everybody hear me
is the audio working
yes i will continue so
um
rethinking humanitarian aid specifically
with the help of scientific knowledge
and scientific methods but let me begin
and introduce our session by explaining
the work the exact type of work that is
being done in human in the humanitarian
sector
and what we folk focus on so of course
all of you are familiar with it from the
media let me make it more specific
humanitarian work helps people oops
helps people affected by crisis
so it's about people and so you will see
scenes like these these are all
photographs from medaire a specific
organization but this is typical of work
that's being done by many organizations
you've heard of before
so what we're seeing here um are our
scenes from uh
migrant camps and and uh health clinics
and so on humanitarian assistance is
about saving lives first and foremost
it's about alleviating suffering
it's about relief and recovery during
and after man-made crises and natural
disasters and it's also about preventing
and strengthening
preparedness for when such situations
occur it's not always just reactive it
is proactive
and of course it's about caring for the
most needy and vulnerable people in the
world today
maintaining human dignity i want to
become more specific before we start
talking about how science plays a role
in this so there are very typical types
of programs that are delivered by
humanitarian organizations
there is
medical programs in which
of course clinics are run and medical
care is provided
so that humanitarian workers are
providing nutrition they're providing
health care
and counseling
the second type of program is called
wash in which
water and sanitary
facilities are provided for people in
need the specific type of work that is
that is executed there are wells being
drilled bore holes
the construction of latrines which is
closely related of course to the medical
care because sanitary conditions are
essential for good health and today in
our times of pandemic also providing
hand-washing facilities
and then
there are shelter programs in which in
which yeah exactly that shelter is
provided for people who are exposed to
the elements as a result of natural
disasters that means building homes
building temporary shelters tents
also disaster proof homes
it is it includes the distribution of
non-food items like blankets and
tarpaulins and so on this can also
include repairing or creating
infrastructure
for for the delivery of the items in
addition to these three principal types
of program meaning medical
uh wash and shelter
humanitarian work
involves education
peace building and protection you've
heard of some of these things through
the new news but
when we talk about the programs that we
support it is specifically about making
these
this work more effective and efficient
all of this work takes place in a
completely different context from what
we know in our civilian lives so the the
context of humanitarian work is
particularly challenging as we can
imagine so it happens at a time of
crisis
it usually
strikes
regions that are suffering from poverty
to begin with so if a disaster if an
earthquake strikes in japan it may not
become a humanitarian case simply
because
of the the resource richness that that
exists and the the institutional
robustness of the context
humanitarian work takes place in
poverty-stricken regions where we where
that are resource poor and where the the
institutions are not as strong of course
we we struggle or the the aid workers
struggle with corruption with chaos
and and conflict and violence
this results
in limited access to the people in need
so you can't just go there the
challenges to actually getting the work
done means first establishing access a
huge challenge um the people that we
work with or the the beneficiaries there
may not have the education that the
educational levels that exist um in
richer parts of the world not for out of
any fault of their own but places that
are that are stricken by by chaos and by
conflict tend to have low infrastructure
for educating the population this is a
challenge for aid workers who are trying
to function there infrastructure is
often destroyed or simply does not exist
and of course there are environmental
challenges
so before we start talking about the
solutions that science can provide here
and and support in the work uh i want to
give you an overview of why
we even have to
see the moral imperative for this work
to improve
um contrary to what
many of us might think when we hear
media campaigns to please contribute
to
to humanitarian efforts to
in in times of crisis when an earthquake
occurs or when there is is conflict and
crisis in a region
humanitarian funding in the world as a
whole has been steadily increasing in
the past decades so we're talking about
a huge amount of resources being poured
into the humanitarian sector
and the first
the first graph that you see here comes
from a publication by professor cabonier
who is the vice president of the
international red cross and he is
actually starting up the field of
humanitarian economics simply on the
premise that the amount of money going
into the system is increasing
dramatically
over time and here you can see another
picture that goes a little bit further i
don't have data from the last seven
years but you clearly see the trend
emergency funding has risen tenfold in
the last 14 years so any impression
you've had that there is no money going
into these projects it's simply not true
it doesn't mean that the challenges do
not exist so let me try and explain to
that the biggest donors are not you and
me they're not private people who are
opening their purses these are
institutional donors these are nations
and you can see an overview right here
nevertheless the if the good news that
is that that more money is being
directed to need in the world the bad
news is that it's simply not enough
because the need is growing faster than
the resources um are being provided for
that so if you see here um the data from
uni uno cha um the people in need are
are shown in in red in 2021
that's 235 million people in need
but funding has been targeted for
much less than that than that number 159
million this year so there is um there
is a difference
and we've seen it growing over time as
the trend will show so 79 more people in
2021 than than 2019 this is um
this is obviously a great deal of
pressure in the system even as the
resources poured in increase so
we talk about
a funding gap
we face a dilemma
because
the work is increasing um exactly at
this pace the resources are increasing
but not enough so the needs are growing
uh the needs are are bigger than um
the the funding that's going in there so
what are the things that we can do faced
with exactly this dilemma
so um the speakers here today the eth
and its humanitarian operations and
supply chain management lab the other
lab that will be presented here today
the work the the scientific work is
addressing exactly this gap and this
dilemma we come to the conclusion that
there are only three things you can do
if you have a funding gap and you have
increasing need in the world you can
either reduce the need
politicians are working very hard
to do this so nevertheless if you look
at cases like south sudan where
humanitarian organizations have had
missions there for over 30 years they're
basically a permanent fixture in in
countries like this reducing the need
will not happen quickly and it may never
happen at all
there are many success stories in
humanitarian aid doesn't mean we really
have the influence over the original
need we don't see that as the most
promising
initiative although we should not stop
trying
we can increase the funding by all means
and dr paris will talk about that later
if you have a system that's inefficient
our experience as industrial engineers
is that pumping in more resources does
not improve outcomes
and that's what we will be discussing
showing today in more detail our attempt
or our strategy for this is to make the
money we have go further um we are
supply chain management engineers um and
so one of the things that one of the
ways that we describe our work is saying
doing more with less
so this is what we will describe today
here are our three speakers i'd like to
introduce um
lea rouge who will finish her doctorate
i'd like to call her dr
but legally i'm not allowed to but she
will finish her doctorate
in february
she is actually not an industrial
engineer but she uses scientific methods
as a psychologist to support
more productivity and organizations she
targets better behavior to make the work
better so she will be showing you in
detail how to measure and model the
behaviors of people and then testing
these effects to improve leadership
so leah will be our first speaker our
second speaker will be dr andrew paris
he's process excellence manager at
medaire a small ngo
in switzerland
close to geneva
and he will be talking about improving
the system of work itself i i describe
the three types of programs now um what
could we do to make uh the work that
goes into um delivering health care or
or providing a clean water how could we
reduce waste in the work that is done
there and he will show you how an
industrial method
targets exactly this and it has a very
very interesting uh team and
organizational effect
team productivity and and
and the behavior and the uh the
interpersonal behavior improves as uh
the work processes become uh less
wasteful and and um
uh
uh
less convoluted so it's also a way of
improving team engagement which is very
important obviously and i will close
with a
final
presentation very brief that is very
timely today and this is not strictly
speaking a humanitarian crisis but we
are working in a resource-poor
environment to improve preparedness for
epidemic response in uganda i will give
you um a quick overview of what that
project is doing which is of course of
personal interest to us all because the
world is embroiled
in the pandemic and so it's about
getting medical supply to the right
place at the right time to respond
to sudden pandemics and with that i'm
sorry if that introduction was a little
bit fast we have a lot to present to you
today i'd like to pass on to our first
speaker leah rusch
here you go
thank you very much for introducing me
and hello also from my side
it's a pleasure to be here and to talk
about our work today which is about the
human element in humanitarian operations
so
during the refugee crisis the peak of
the refugee crisis in 2015 there was
over a million of people in need
luckily though there were also thousands
of people out there really motivated and
ready to help
and back then that made me curious back
then i was a student in organization and
psychology and i was wondering how can
we make this work how can we use this
powerful movement in order to make
humanitarian aid more effective
so i reached out to aid workers as well
as to researchers and ask them what do
you think what do you do what do we need
in order to make humanitarian aid as a
whole more effective
and they said we have to cooperate
better so what did they mean by that
so when a disaster strikes there are
hundreds of organizations out there in
order to help
and this picture here is only a small
excerpt of the total humanitarian
landscape
so all these organizations are trying to
help however what they are facing is
restricted funding
so in this
figure by the united nations archer you
see that almost half of what was
required by the humanitarian sector was
ultimately not delivered to it
and that's why the united nations
and their sustainable development goal
for better partnerships for global
development
to improve partnerships the united
nations itself set up the cluster system
and this resonates also with research
and what research tells us so research
in humanitarian operations basically
says we need clusters so that means we
need coordination platforms where
representatives from humanitarian
organizations can meet and coordinate
with each other
and we furthermore need a cluster lead
so an organization and persons
coordinating this information exchange
and resource exchange between the
organizations
and this is reflected in practice so
over a decade ago the cluster system by
the united nations was set up which
comprises different sections for
humanitarian aid for instance
food nutrition shelter as well as
logistics
and each cluster is hosted by a cluster
lead
so what the cluster lead does is it
organizes regular meetings in the field
in affected regions as well as on a
global level
where representatives from humanitarian
organizations are coming together in
order to exchange resources with each
other and by resources i mean
information as well as material
resources needed in order to tackle the
humanitarian response
and by political mandate this cluster
lead also functions as the last resort
so that means in case they are striking
resource gaps so we already alluded to
this there are striking resource gaps so
imagine the scenario there is an
organization that needs certain material
resources such as trucks in order to
bring their relief items to an affected
region and they do not have these
resources then the cluster lead has to
come in and provide these resources
so what you see is the whole system is
in place we have a system that properly
works and is there in order to
facilitate coordination however what we
see is that coordination is still one of
the biggest challenges to successful
humanitarian aid so the earthquake in
haiti in 2010 was one striking example
where coordination between all these
eight actors didn't really work out and
it even became labeled as if as a huge
failure in scientific case studies
and that led me then specifically to the
question
well how can that be
why is cooperation still so difficult
even though there is a system in place
that is there to facilitate coordination
so there may be something in it
perhaps the human element that is
driving the difficulties shaping
cooperation
so and in our research
that doesn't come as a surprise because
i'm an organizational psychologist i
wanted to examine how
the humans in the system working for
humanitarian organizations and in aid
teams how they shape humanitarian aid as
a whole operations outcomes and by
operations i mean
tangible tangible numbers measure
everything that is measurable basically
how many beneficiaries were served and
received help and how efficiently and
effectively did they receive this help
so this is the approach
of my research
so now i will show you the specific
studies that we conducted
during my phd my team from the quinoa
logistics university and i
so we set up a research institute
institute that is called reloa so if you
find this interesting you you can also
go on our website and see the studies
that our team is conducting so one of
these studies is
focused on the cluster system
so here our research question was what
kind of leadership styles does the
cluster need in order to be successful
and here we first reached out to the
people working in the system because
i wanted to give voice to them and let
them speak and let them share their
experiences that they made in the field
and in these cluster meetings
so i specifically asked them
why is coordination so difficult and
what do we need in order to improve it
well and what we found is what they were
saying
the system is great and they highly
appreciate it
however at the same time they often face
these power struggles in the system
which may be at the first site
contradicting contradicting humanitarian
aid as such because we would think they
all have the same objective of course
they they want to cooperate to make it
happen
however what we find is due to these
restricted resources
the eight actors finding themselves in
power struggles
so when they then come to these meetings
in the field
where resources financial resources
logistics resources are allocated then
they of course also want to benefit from
this resource allocation to make their
response happen if they then feel
we are not getting what we want
then it's upsetting for them this is
human so they do not get what they want
and this even so this feeling this anger
becomes even worse if they are observing
that the cluster lead
itself has two heads so let me explain
what i mean by the cluster lead having
two heads
so what sometimes happens is that the
cluster lead coordinating these meetings
by mandate and also by mandate being
responsible to provide the missing
resources
often runs operations itself
so that is the cluster lead may
sometimes have an interest itself to
benefit from these meetings and thereby
also prioritizing its own needs as
opposed to cluster members needs
and this is upsetting for the cluster
and decreases trust among the cluster
members in in in the whole approach
on a positive note though they were also
sharing scenarios where coordination
works really well
and here they described a pure
facilitator approach of the cluster lead
that means a cluster lead that does not
run any operations
and that on top
serves a neutral agenda so neutrally
allocating the resources to the cluster
members
so in
another study we were checking what kind
of communication styles can help to
improve the information sharing between
humanitarian actors as well as the
public
and here we use social media data
because especially to the pandemic where
we all found ourselves in remote
realities social media became an even an
even more important communications means
so here we were asking are there
specific communication styles that
improve the information diffusion of
actional advice what should be done and
what shouldn't be done
during during the pandemic
and here we distinguish two specific
communication styles
that we infered from communication
guidelines such as
the guideline by the world health
organization so this word the word
health organization and other scientists
called for authentic communication so
experts such as humanitarian aid workers
they should communicate authentically
what can be done or what cannot be done
so certainty
also as well as uncertainty
but at the same time they should also
signal confidence so that we can make it
happen
so then
scraping the social media data and using
quantitative text mining methods as well
as multi
statistical analyses but i do not mean
to bore anybody with that and to become
too nerdy in that regard however so what
we found here and that may be
interesting is that confidence during
such precarious times as the pandemic
may not be as important as authenticity
so we found that
authentic communication is actually
really driving the information sharing
and information diffusion of actional
advice during
aid workers as well as the public
so the last study i would like to
show you today is
also a social media study and here we
measured over two years to what extent
humanitarian organizations actually
cross promote each other in social media
and what we find is that the
cross-promotion unfortunately is still
quite low however we also find that some
groups cooperate more with each other
than others and these are those so the
institutionally funded organizations so
those that get the funding from the
institutional donors those are the ones
cross-promoting each other however we
found that the privately funded
organizations may be a little bit more
competitive in that regard and not
cross-promoting
other privately funded organizations or
institutionally funded organizations
so these dynamics speak to so we
try we made the inference that the type
of funding
may create certain identities these
organizations feel identities
identification between a certain type of
organization that then also drives their
cooperation
thank you for your attention and now i
would like to
hand over to
andrew
[Applause]
all right thank you very much
um all right so my name is andy paris
again process excellence manager at
meador humanitarian ngo based near
lausanne in switzerland
and i guess it's up to me to get there
there we go all right so i want to talk
about
improving the system of work and in fact
we talked about
there are a couple of things we can do
we can reduce the need we can increase
the funding or we can make the money go
farther and we and what i'm going to
talk about is reducing the system of
work through something called lean
now some of you might ask the question
well what is
lean we'll talk about that so most of
the private sector many parts of the
public sector are very familiar with
what lean is
um it's what enabled toyota
to
re to become the leading car company in
the world
it's also at google amazon and you can
see a number of uh companies who are
famous for doing lean
um have done to grow their market share
grow their profits empower their people
also
specifically
according to the lean enterprise
institute there's a this definition of
lean that it is the way of thinking
about creating needed value with fewer
resources and less waste it's also a
prac set of practices consisting of
continuous experimentation and that's
where the scientific part comes in
in order to achieve perfect value with
zero waste so to rephrase these a little
bit we could say lean empowers and
expects people to improve how they do
their work through science through the
scientific method we'll talk about that
more of continuous improvement in order
to reduce waste and increase value the
value that the company provides to its
customers or in the case of humanitarian
work to the people in need of people in
crisis whom we're serving
lean also has the double benefit of
reducing the burden on people
it's it's a very heavy load to not have
enough resources and have so many needs
out there
um and to have so many crises that are
coming our way but we talked uh
initially about some of the challenges
that we face in the humanitarian context
this will help reduce the burden because
we're not running stepping over our own
toes in order to get the work done so
we're reducing them burden on employees
promoting their creativity and also
learning within the organization so what
is the scientific part of lean it's
basically this this this uh this way of
formulating a hypothesis about what will
work and then testing to see if that
hypothesis works
this is the famous plan do check act
cycle that was developed by edwards
deming
and then the planned part of it
basically what one does is
define the problem the problem is the
gap between where we are and where we
want to be
the number of people with with
food that they can get daily easily
for example the number of children uh
suffering from malaria or whatever the
case may be
but we're also looking at this now
internal internally to the organization
we're defined the problem maybe it takes
us too long to get our
our humanitarian supply chain needs in
order to deliver them to people maybe it
takes us too long to hire people
etc we measure
the
way things are currently happening we
analyze it understand the root causes
and then we put a plan together for how
to act when to act who's going to do
what all those things we normally do in
our planning and then we implement we do
we make the change
and too often what often happens is
people will stop there and say okay
let's keep going but the scientific
method
insists that what we do is we measure it
we check to see did we make a difference
and if not we're going to go back around
in the backwards direction if if we did
get what we wanted to achieve then we go
forward we act and we we
incorporate the the new learning and we
we move forward with the new way of
doing things so this is our scientific
approach of lean which we want to
consider
how does this work in humanitarian
operations
humanitarians love toyota vehicles they
are reliable they are tough they go the
distance they don't need much repair
but does this system and lean comes from
toyota toyota production system does
this system that was developed by lean
also work okay their cars work but does
their management system work in ngos
that's the question that maybe this
young man is thinking about
um so we can ask the question what could
the impact of lean be in an ngo well
i'll share with you some experience now
and the simple answer it's similar to
what it is in the corporate world if
anyone's familiar with with uh with the
changes impacts 40 reduction of this 50
reduction that it's a similar type of a
thing
so i spent some time with world vision
another large international ngo
living in east africa working and
training my colleagues there in lean
lean six sigma concepts and things that
we were able to do is to reduce over a
million and a half dollars annually in
supply chain costs mostly
reduce the span time the time it takes
to do things for example in in processes
where we targeted we reduced almost 60
percent of the time it takes to do
certain things
and we also began to develop a culture
of continuous improvement just getting
people thinking about making small
changes a little bit here a little bit
there every day
some specific examples i won't go
through them but you can see
similar to what one finds in the
corporate world not surprisingly uh
processes are have have a number of
similarities 40 50 percent improvements
80 improvements um
in in various processes that we took on
so we can get these uh similar results
also what can be the impact
so in meadow the ngo that i currently
work
work in we've also realized significant
improvements um i want to point out in
particular a case study
um that bubble and i documented
on the meta response to the
uh
to the uh beirut blast back in august
4th of last year
and the ability of people to respond
quickly to adapt on the ground the
leadership communication practices etc
were really instrumental in empowering
in enabling meadow to have a great
response
so that's the
uh some reference on that now
one might ask the question okay andrew
you've told us about this thing called
lean what's so new about lean these are
some gentlemen who are kind of the
founding fathers of lean uh in fact
there's nothing new about lean it's been
around for
30 to 70 years depending on
when you about 30 years ago when the
term lean was coined but but before that
it was a toyota thing
um but
ver and lean now is applied in virtually
every every sector every every industry
in governments militaries even are
applying lean
it is a proven approach to continuously
improving in the pursuit of excellence
so that's not the new part
then the question is well what is the
new part
well the new part is to apply this in
ngos in the work in the humanitarian
work that's the thing that's new
um we recently did a a very brief
informal survey of a number of
leaders in humanitarian organizations
asking the questions do you know
anything about lean
and
how much do you know about lean and 87
percent responded we know little to
nothing about lean
none of them said we know how to do it
well enough to teach anyone else
um
but on the other hand 61 percent said we
would like to benefit from this sounds
interesting but we don't know where to
start
22 percent have begun but still our
novices and nobody says they're in
they're good at it or again could could
uh
uh
are experts in in the process
but there's an opportunity here where we
could light the fuse and and get this
rocket going if we can apply lean and
really have dramatic impact in the
humanitarian sector
and development sectors as well
so there's an irony and this and this is
the irony
development and humanitarian principles
are
very similar to lean principles
so let's go through a couple of these
and
we'll go through them now so the first
fundamental thing that you
learn about when you're going to do
development work or humanitarian work is
you need to show respect you for the
people you treat the people you're
serving with dignity and you are there
to serve them not to tell them what to
do
you're not there
to uh to
you are there to provide value to them
you're not there
to tell them what to do you're not there
to do things for them
uh the people who are in need are the
people who are experts in being in in in
poverty or in in the in the crisis they
know what the problems are they often
know what the solutions are we need to
ask them we need to involve them we need
to work with them
in humanitarian work and development
work we're also trained to do things as
simply as and easy as visually as
possible and it's a great uh
picture here of of a
mid upper arm measurement for for
malnutrition
it's a color coded very simple
technique that almost anyone with a
little bit of training can do it's it's
a simple approach and that's one of the
the concepts of lean interestingly
um we build people up
we build people up in order to empower
them to to make their lives better and
inside of an organization we want to
build up employees to make their
processes better to make their work
better and there's this last point here
create plan as we talked about
experiment
and monitor the outputs monitor the
impact that we're having this is what
ngos do day in and day out they monitor
they evaluate in the cycle they do that
again and again to see is the
intervention working are we having the
desired impact
so the irony is
ngos aren't doing this in their own
work they're not applying the principles
that they apply in the field in their
own operations but at the same time it's
not just irony it's also an opportunity
because and i found this to be truly the
case
ngos will also more readily understand
and accept and be able to say yeah this
lean thing this makes sense once they
hear about it because it is so familiar
to them it is something that is natural
to them
so the novelty where's the novelty the
novelty isn't applying scientific
thinking
to the humanitarian operations not just
to to the field work that we do and
seeing if what we're doing is having an
impact
it's in applying a proven private sector
corporate world approach management
system inside the ngo world which which
is often nervous about these types of
things
it's also an applying development and
humanitarian principles again inside the
organization not just outside the
organization in the work that we do
and it's about empowering
and expecting employees to improve we're
building the capacity of our employees
to improve how they do their work and
we're expecting them to do that work
setting targets for improvement and
expecting them to work better over time
improve how they do their work
and uh as we do that we are making the
money go farther by what what we're
doing though is we're cutting the waste
we're cutting the things that are
preventing us from making progress
rather than cutting the value that we're
actually adding to communities who are
in crisis
so to
summarize very briefly lean
does help us to rethink our humanitarian
aid and to make it better thank you
so thanks andrew i just want to remind
the audience here in the room and also
out in cyberspace that
after my last presentation we will go
over to a panel discussion and we
encourage you to submit your questions
to us because i realize this is very
complex material and that it's not we
cannot explain all the details um in the
presentations itself so we encourage you
to ask focused questions
but we're definitely seeing after the
first two presentations that there is
great potential and and uh projects have
had success in applying evidence-based
scientific methods to what we call the
work of the heart when we think of of
helping people and humanitarian aid
a great deal of resources but also a
great deal of good intentions are being
poured into this system that has become
an economy of its own but
we believe that scientific methods can
serve to make good intentions go further
so let me provide a last example from
our own humanitarian operations and
supply chain management lab at eth
zurich we have multiple projects running
right now not all of them
i can share with you i'm glad to share
more but i'd like to again show you um
sort of our intermediate results from a
running project that is about a topic
that is affecting all of our lives right
now and that is the work we're doing
with the ministry of health in uganda um
to improve logistics preparedness for
disease outbreaks in that country and uh
what many of us don't know and what
scientific evidence-based methods do
reveal we can look at a system and we
think we understand it but we don't but
logistics as a function in humanitarian
organizations can consume up to 80
percent of budget so the budgets that i
showed you that are now running in the
billions of dollars um you know there's
if 80 of those are logistics and and the
logistics is not working well the money
is not going as far as it can it's
really not about corruption or overhead
those are two myths we'd like to address
later but there's potential for
improvement to make the processes work
better make the resources go further
this is why we are paying attention to
this and putting all of the resources
the brain resources of our eth lab
behind it so the problem we are
addressing there is something very
specific to this country
because of its geographic location
because of the the conditions in that
country
mostly the proximity of human
populations
living near animal populations also
migratory patterns of birds
there's a great deal of zoonotic
zoonotic
disease development those are
pathogens that develop that become
dangerous uh infectious diseases by
spreading from animal to human
and we were asked and and um this
country copes without many of us knowing
this copes quite heroically um with a
list of ten
we just looked at a list of around ten
right diseases that occur regularly they
know it will happen
it will it will break out they just
don't know when
and where but it's coming and i'm
showing you a few examples here ebola
scary
but the others are just a scary crimean
congo hemorrhagic fever malaria
cholera and now of course coveted 19.
these outbreaks tend to occur in remote
locations with poor infrastructure they
also come in from the bad neighbors that
uganda has
south sudan congo and so on these
extremely
poverty stricken
conflict regions so these are remote
locations as i said makes the work very
difficult so their question is a natural
one how much material meaning medical
supply should be pre-positioned in which
location to optimize medic
outcomes for patients by by the way this
is a question that every single health
ministry in the world is asking
themselves today um but this is uh this
is a challenge to um the authorities in
uganda every single day for us it's it's
new in its urgency so this is a question
we approached with our scientific method
and the urgency could not be greater um
you know if ebola outbreak if it breaks
out in uganda and spreads from the
border to the city um it will be it will
have disastrous consequences for 45
million people in the country and should
it spread beyond the borders it might um
affect us as well so
we have had very good experiences in
using scientific methods to work on this
problem and not just medically but
really logistics methods which is what
we do at our lab so our
humanitarian operations and supply chain
management lab began working with the
ministry of health there in 2019 already
in the on the ebola response that was
our first encounter and we had very
positive experiences with that it was
also about what what um leah has been
studying um from the psychological side
it was also about collaboration of
multiple organizations trying
to respond together
and then in 2021
our project was looking at basically all
the whole list of diseases together with
the ministry it's a close partnership
now we conducted in this year we just
completed a comprehensive baseline study
where we exactly measured what what is
not working out right now you know so we
just don't you know they tend to
um
to believe you can go into a problem set
like this and have good performance
without a plan is simply
naive we know that that is not true in
any other situation and still it tends
to happen in a humanitarian situation
because it's urgent let's just go out
and do that do that
the scientific method says do a baseline
first we confirmed
something very specific that that would
only have been possible
because of the research that we do at
our chair at eth is that the regular
healthcare supply chain which otherwise
performs well does not fit the emergency
needs and you need a specific supply
chain for that and this creates not only
underperformance in the supply of
medical goods in this extremely critical
situation it creates terrible stress for
healthcare workers and the ministry
so they have already realized that a
decentralization of material storage
would accelerate response but now they
have evidence so they're replacing
opinions and power struggles with uh
evidence uh that is
impersonal and yeah
something that that uh speaks for itself
and what we have definitely uncovered is
that the the system there has existing
assets infrastructure and expertise
which uh
which is which is a huge advantage and
it's not just
a situation with with weaknesses but
there are great strengths
that should be measured and put into
place to make
the the resources that they have uh go
further so i will just give you a quick
summary of what we're doing next after
the baseline study we're in the in the
midst of the solution search right now
and we are um
computing my colleagues uh i have
several uh sub teams working on this um
we are creating a mathematical model to
answer the question how much
where
how much to store and where
and
in order to have the the best possible
preparedness for an outbreak based on
historical data or just based on where
we expect
the need will occur
and this is fairly complex calculation
can't be done by themselves they don't
have uh you know this is this is the
support that we can provide from the
university um in the same spirit of or
applying the methods also that andrew
has just described so far we are working
on process improvements to design the
emergency response system
in addition to their regular health care
to say okay what do you do when it's
really an emergency
so it works
so it's faster and
and
for example that ppe meaning personal
protective equipment is not ransacked by
regular hospitals if someone takes out
gloves to deliver a baby obviously that
kit will not be really
very useful then for for isolating um an
evil a patient and so on so these these
are very very simple things as andrew
said but small incremental improvements
when they add up uh make a huge
difference in performance so
we're working on that too on their their
processes and of course um
all sorts of analytics to to make
including uh
interviews and focus groups which are
more interactive uh forms of solution
search to make best use of their
resources and these resources include
the people the medical supply and the
finance and what we're discovering is
that if we just improve the way the
people work together you can take very
little financial resources and make it
go very far
um and so this is what uh i'd like to
share with you um what we are confident
will happen out of this project is that
we will be able to spread by share best
practices from uganda to the rest of the
world
because as i said they are doing a
heroic job there
with very little and
you know the pandemic has shown that our
own ministries of health and cdc's
have not been very very efficient in the
response that we have had enormously
wasteful
covered responses and so
i hope this was interesting to you i
would like to
to
move on to the panel discussion
we're going to sit down together and
answer your questions and and and have a
discussion to make this a little more
detailed for you so
[Applause]
do we have
do we already have questions from
from the audience
yes hello uh thank you very much for
sharing your thoughts and insights into
this matter quite a lot quite a lot of
it was was new to me uh thanks very much
for that um
you addressed the the the people factor
the uh
all three of you um but is there also a
technological
development you would crave for i'd be
interested to to hear from all three of
you are there certain technological
developments maybe future developments
but certain developments that would aid
your particular world uh work um
uh
on uh
in the countries of need or in the
regions of need or in a more general
sense for logistics for example so is
other technological
assets or new new developments new tools
new methods new toys
machines
that that could aid your particular work
the future
do you want to take that
well i'll try one um
i mean if there's a technology to get
people to be kinder to each other that
would be a great place to start
transportation is one of the primary
challenges that we have so getting
goods from one place to another getting
people for that for that matter from one
place to another as well
the communication infrastructure also is
a big challenge to us so
why internet capabilities uh those types
of things
um
medical
obviously if there were medical
developments that would
and i know they're being made progress
even now in you know
a vaccine or something to prevent
malaria those types of things which
should get rid of waterborne help us
reduce waterborne diseases that's the
primary challenge so
um i don't know there's one silver
bullet that comes to my mind uh but
there are a variety of things that we
definitely would benefit from the
greater technological advancements as
well
i would add to that that i resist and
the temptation to look for a silver
bullet
and
a technology is a tool
if it is not used and this is something
we know from the pr for profit sector we
know from industry and we know this from
almost every other context
you know if we have toys uh and we don't
use them and we don't implement them the
value will be zero and the investment
you put into that asset is zero so we
dream of i.t systems we dream of drones
with the exception of medical
breakthroughs okay a vaccine we will
always need
you know better forms of water
purification and things like absolutely
but certainly from our logistics
background what we're seeing is is um
you know if people
if we have processes that work
better and we often don't even have
visibility of the whole process
but if we could just see where they
break down where are the bottlenecks
where where does the communication stop
uh where uh
yes where
do we lack the understanding where do we
lack the the information we need to make
a good decision
so if we could just cl make the system
better that way
it's we're seeing excellent results with
low tech and what we saw in our
beirut case study is that and and just
now this i think it was this morning or
yesterday this week i had a focus group
with uganda and they were saying you
know
we have whatsapp
and we organized the last mile
distribution with whatsapp
and our beirut case study said you know
things are changing so fast on the
ground and everything's destroyed they
can't dial into some big fancy i.t
system that might be set up in
switzerland they're using their phones
they're using cheap fast easy technology
that everyone
can intuitively use without training
that's what we need we don't need you
know putting a drone plopping a drone
into an office does not solve anything
we have to have a process that turns
that the use of that drone into
re you know actually uh creating more
material availability in a certain place
and that's like a
multi-functional cross-functional
um uh
task so um please let's stop and this is
true of all of us let's not think about
silver bullets let's think about the
system
if i may add something to that
especially in regard to communication i
mean it's quite obvious that there are
so many
technologies communication technologies
out there and platforms where
humanitarian aid workers can exchange
information with each other and that is
very quick information so where wherever
they are they can quickly capture this
information whether it be if they take a
photo for instance or writing a message
and they can upload it for instance to
social media or to a whatsapp group so i
think one of the challenges here again
is of having so many technologies which
is of course on the one hand an asset on
the other hand though there need to be
authorized people also that filter these
information and that again
provide an infrastructure for this
communication exchange perhaps bringing
all these information again together in
a platform and making it available it's
extremely challenging also to
distinguish reliable information from
unreliable information so that as one
insight that i also retrieved from
from cluster meetings where this is
highly discussed and where people are in
charge information office
offices in order to filter
these information that come in
via technology so um in regard to
technical innovation so it's it's great
to have it and you have this exchange
but
it also needs then some so the challenge
is to establish or to structure it again
so
there are two questions here from
cyberspace
uh there's one that that i can answer
very quickly at the top and the second
one i'll pass on to you andrew the first
one is i don't know if you can see it no
you can't do international
humanitarian organizations and agencies
have logistics or supply chain experts
on their payroll if not why not the
answer is they do
and so that simply exists we we've we're
seeing also in the past
they helped me but definitely the past
10 to 20 years a professionalization of
logistics in the sector and we're seeing
very mature and sophisticated and
brilliant managers
uh dedicating their lives to making this
better that that has definitely and the
simple simply the existence of the
logistics cluster pays tribute to that
so yes there's specific know-how being
built up there and organizational
roles made for that so yes that exists
and some of them are coming from the
corporate sector and some are coming
from the corporate sector too
so um the other question i think is very
interesting a very controversial
question straight out of the media today
it comes from cusack and he says lean
has been criticized during the coveted
pandemic when there were stockouts
just in time was considered the was
given the blame as the factor for low
stocks how can we tackle these issues
andrew is this is this the solution or
is this the problem i know you can talk
about this one also maybe you have
something to add
to what i say
um
so
lean helps an organization become more
flexible more adaptable more able to
respond quickly to shocks to the system
and certainly kova 19 restrictions are a
huge shock to the system
yes
the goal is to reduce your your
inventory
in order to make again make the
organization more efficient if if an
organization is ready and able to
respond to shocks then they will be able
to respond to to to the kobe 19. so
um it's made organizations more flexible
the thing is having a supplier in china
um a long ways away is actually not a
terribly lean thing to do
so uh rather having
the supply chain closer to you so if you
look at toyota and where where do most
of the supports part suppliers uh in the
intuitive factory
are where they located they're mostly
located around the actual factory itself
so they're actually practicing what
they're preaching they also have
strategic stocks which is something
that's not talked about so much here
there are strategic stocks that the
companies do have in order to address
the potential crisis that may that may
occur and those um those will then help
them through but if if you can
quickly start up somewhere else another
supplier closer by because you know what
the design of the part is you know how
to produce it and you can get another
another vendor up and running quickly
that is going to make you more flexible
and not so liable to uh stockouts but
maybe you have a couple cents to add on
that one too actually this is this is
something i've been i've been trying to
explain to many people
during this crisis and i'm always
outraged by by the media coverage that
says that you know all companies in the
world have become too lean and that's
why we don't have uh toilet paper for
three hours
in the supermarket this week
i think lean should never be taken
literally
as
say as being the equivalent of having no
stock first of all not every single
supply chain every single company is
different and it and as it should be it
should be uh customized and and
strategically fit to its purpose
lean is not does not mean no stock lean
does not mean
just in time only that's one of the
tools but it's not all lean is a system
of thinking that is about removing waste
about continuous improvement about
orientation to the customer lean is not
the problem during the pandemic lean has
definitely been part of the solution
because of the methods that were applied
by commercial companies if they if they
hadn't been as agile and lean as they
were um you know we would have seen much
worse
problems in in our civilian life so i
won't go into that further i do
recommend
the the blog posts of my colleague
professor netland
at eth where he gives very detailed uh
explanations of this but i think we'll
stick to our humanitarian questions here
and and so these were the two questions
that came from cyberspace how about
are there any any other here in the
audience
is there anything else you'd like to
know in more detail about some of the
work we're doing
good evening
i have a question considering like the
finances
um
it's a matter of fact that
a lot a huge problem is that
all the donations from the countries are
mostly bound to
certain projects
and the ngos don't have like
a lot of access to us or can't decide
where to put it
and i wonder how your opinion is how
much of an impact has
changing the internal system
considering that
changing the system the internal system
i mean the donation system do you want
to take this i know that there's
research at your university yes yeah
exactly my supervisor maria mitsubishi
is doing research on the type of funding
organizations receive and what kind of
impact that has on their performance so
and i think one highly criticized
type of funding is the earmarked funding
pegged funding exactly what you
mentioned exactly what you mentioned so
where organizations
receive a specific purpose they have to
they have to execute in regard to that
so they get the money to do something
specific with it and that can be that
can be and that um in that regard
destructive because very often the
organizations may need the money for
something else and they are the ones who
may better know what this donation is is
needed for so actually what um what was
seen is that that also led to a high
amount of waste right absolutely it does
that is the problem because they
couldn't really use what was donated
i think
i can only reiterate this point the
research clearly
has demonstrated this in in
multiple contexts it doesn't matter what
program it is doesn't matter what type
of organization what type of crisis
earmarked funding actually creates waste
in general and obviously different
degrees of waste
simply because you can um you cannot
predict in advance without understanding
the system
where the need will be greatest and so
um you know a donor
donors a
a colleague of mine recently said donors
actually reduce the optimal space
with the best of intentions and this is
where science is so interesting and so
revealing when we take our scientific
methods we realize we had the best of
intentions it looked intuitively correct
but we we create so many unintended
consequences and earmarked funding i
think comes from lack of trust in the
organizations we believe they are they
are the organizations are corrupt or we
believe they have way too much overhead
we're dealing with a lot of myths here
that actually
hold
humanitarian work back from its maximum
impact and earmarked funding is uh in in
in all research shown to be that way
could give many many examples but i
won't go into that here yeah now say
part of the solution to that is for the
institutional donors
to have the understanding that
life life in the field changes and there
are there are these things are
unpredictable we don't know how how
things will progress over the year
you know coven may strike us and we need
to respond to a different crisis than we
thought that we originally had or their
floods come or whatever it is
um i mean in my experience our donors
are as flexible i mean try to be quite
flexible um they have a certain
commitment you know they have to be
responsible to the taxpayers the
taxpayers give give you know give the
money and
they say look you're going to feed this
many people you're going to try and
reduce the incidence of water-borne
disease by by this much
and
that's what we work towards um i'll say
on the other on the other hand
there there is a benefit to having a
gold you know something that we're
working towards something hard because
the alternative would be well here
just go and do good
but if we don't have targets if we don't
have specific objectives
um honestly maybe we might not spend
that as we might not work as hard as we
otherwise might in order to achieve
those specific goals
and
if if you if you remember that the
charter front
the unmet need is huge and this the met
need is actually quite small so even if
we're you know not meeting we're never
going to meet all the unmet need we're
always only going to meet a part of it
um is that the you know the most
absolutely most important part we don't
know
you know we try to find that that's what
we try and propose to the institutional
donors and we work on that and then when
things change we do ask them can we
change this can we modify this and when
when covet came around we saw that most
of the institutional donors are ready
very writing willing to modify to say
yes you can do this propose us what you
want to do differently change your
targets change how you your budget
proposal you know give us a new thing
and most of them were quite willing and
flexible to work with us on that so
i think it's not all bad there are
challenges that that it creates but um
there's also some good some good side of
it that
having specific objectives and working
to achieve those is something that
motivates an organization to perform
well
in spite of the the crisis
we have a question from cyberspace
and it comes from gaurav he said
currently where supply chains are
failing as an effective post pandemic
we're almost done by the way we're out
of time um
so he says that supply chains are
failing in the pandemic isn't it the
best time to develop chains with
partnerships of ngos and corporate so
public private partnerships what is your
opinion on that
well so my my impression is at least so
what um what i'm observing that more and
more partnerships are developing between
the private and the humanitarian sector
and perhaps that for private companies
it becomes even more difficult to
distinguish themselves from humanitarian
organizations because especially in the
pandemic they
they became equally also socially
responsible for the public as well as
for the people working in in their
organization and they could also see
that there is a big need for that
transportation asset that they have like
dhl right so absolutely companies
they are massive there so
and they can help
they are so powerful in that regard in
providing aid by providing these assets
to to humanitarian organizations and
also to the public so i think that is a
very positive trend that we are that we
can observe that the sectors are
increasingly merging
exactly and and maybe to add to that um
you know we what we've gone through in
the past two years i think has been an
unprecedented experience for us in the
rich world that we we ourselves went
through a humanitarian crisis that there
were rich countries that could not look
after their their poor people and their
their sick people that there were
shortages of ppe in the us
and this is and so we suddenly were in
the position of the beneficiary and that
the private companies like the
pharmaceutical companies and the
transport companies and the hospitals
and so on the the healthcare providers
were suddenly in a position to show
social uh responsibility so i think i
when i looked at that and i compared it
to the projects we're doing we're
thinking um
certainly uh you know we could learn a
lot from the humanitarian sector so we
just wanted to sort of give them a shout
out for the the remarkable work that
they are doing don't always get a lot of
credit for but yes we're going to need
more partnership between the two and
best practices that go in both
directions we think we have something to
teach the poor
and the weary and those who are a
disadvantage there's a great deal we can
learn from the heroic work that they do
maybe with that um elizabeth we're out
of time
what a shame i just have one really
important question it's about science
and it's come from cyberspace as well
but i had it in my notebook can i have
permission and so i asked both of you
um so both of you are doing scientific
work as super nerds
um and
and we're all super nerds at super nerdy
universities so and um so how did the
the
the people in the field the
practitioners how did they respond um to
your
to your efforts to bring um
science to them
how did they what are the the question
is what are the barriers for for
implementing and for adoption of these
best practices from industry and from
science what are your experiences
sure
um so in fact the
um
the thing that brought me to moving to
uh ken i lived in kenya for three years
working in east africa
and
it was because i shared some of these
ideas with the actual people who are
doing the work this was back when i was
in world vision and they said andrew
this is new to us this is exciting come
and tell us about this teach us
how to do these things that you're
talking about they were actually eager
so the
there was there was genuine interest and
when my favorite thing is when i teach
train someone give them you know the
light bulb goes on so to speak and they
are thinking scientifically about their
work they are applying you know plan do
check act they're making their work
better and they're sharing that with
with others um the the barrier is rather
the organization has too many good
things that they want to do and when the
leaders don't know about lean about the
scientific approach and they comply what
they're doing in the field inside
then it just it gets delegated it gets
de-prioritized
and it doesn't really make the progress
so it's it's
the people are themselves get excited
about it they want to do it but the
organization needs to buy into it commit
to it and make make it happen
yeah well so during my projects
especially during the cluster study we
were in close contact always with the
cluster and the people representing the
cluster and we were always showing them
also our nerdy stuff like the computer
simulation and we were showing them see
this is the meeting and these are the
agents and this is how they interact and
they were like wow okay so it raised
their awareness in regard to this human
element and leadership and how fine
nuances like find changes in leadership
can actually change
operations outcome so that was the first
experience and then the second was so
after the paper was written up
i also shared it with my study
participants so with the people i talked
to um in the beginning of my study so i
shared the study and the first feedback
was like wow do this more often you
researchers scientists because we're
sharing information with you we're
really curious in order to hear what you
make of it so to what results you get so
that was i think first
an important imperative for all
scientists out there that we should
share also the work with our study
participants and then the second was
well um that we made something tangible
for them that we provided them with an
empirical evidence which was really hard
to describe for them so these emotional
power struggles so this um
there's also this
tension between the cluster lead and the
cluster members so they then said well
now we can use it as an empirical
evidence to address these issues in our
teams so and that was
a nice a nice feedback for us as
scientists and
but also highlights the importance
to share to share these results with our
with with the study participants and
practitioners
so thank you
then and thank you for joining us today
and we invite you to contact us
certainly at the eth humanitarian
operations and supply chain lab
it's
on our website and uh you know there are
a lot more details about the work that
we're doing so please uh you know we
look forward to sharing more as we move
forward it's a very growing field by all
means so
we hope it was interesting to you
[Applause]